>> I am thrilled to welcome you to the second
annual online conference for educators,
and I know this is not the first
session today for some of you.
The session today, building deeper
connections to the CCSS, C3 framework
and civic competencies with primary sources.
I'd like to introduce our presenters.
Mara Grujanac is the program director for
the Barat Education Foundation, TPS-Barat,
teaching with primary sources program and the
our American voice civic engagement program.
Mara is responsible for the development
and implementation of both programs,
as well as managing foundation
employees and contractors.
Joining Mara will be Pamela McGreer, member of
the curriculum and professional development team
for the TPS-Barat program for four years
and a retired national board-certified
middle school librarian.
Joining Pamela and Mara will be
Julie Schaul, a learning consulting
who develops transforming professional
development and designs inquiry-based strategies
to enhance literacy, critical
thinking and civic competencies.
Mara, Pamela and Julie, welcome.
>> I'm Julie Schaul, and welcome to the session.
We're really happy to have you join us tonight.
We're going to start with a quick collaborative
primary source analysis, and then we'll work
at how teaching with primary sources
aligns to the common core state standards,
supports the C3 framework and builds
your students to these competencies.
So, some of you may be familiar with the
library's primary source analysis tool,
which is a really great way to
start teaching with primary sources.
It is available in print or digital form.
And while we won't be using this actual form
today, you will be following its format.
TPS Program Director Mara Grujanac
will lead you through this activity.
>> Good evening everyone.
Thank you so much for joining us tonight.
It's really nice to be here.
So you see a photograph on the screen.
Our first task is going to
be to observe the image.
Please take a moment to look at the
details individually and collectively.
Spend a moment observing the photo.
Please describe what you see.
What do you notice first?
Anne, a girl wearing a crinoline
slip under a gingham dress.
Patty sees two people surrounded by a lot
of people who seem to be harassing them.
Carrie sees taunting.
Logan sees faces.
Teresa's building on those gentlemen and
saying they may be making bunny ears.
You might also want to look
at what objects and people,
or objects are shown and how are they arranged?
LaSean sees a young, a black young
lady walking with people taunting her.
Interesting, Faith, that you say you see two
strong-willed well-dressed African-Americans
leading the group.
Angie sees an African-American girl with a
group taunting, white men and boys behind her.
That's great.
Thank you for all of your answers.
Let's move along now.
Our next task is going to be
to reflect on what you see.
We're going to start to make connections
between our background knowledge and the image
to create inferences or hypotheses.
Let's think about the purpose of the photo.
What's it make you think or feel?
When you come into the chat box, try to point
to the evidence that makes you feel that way
when you're looking at the picture.
Faith notices that it's a study in contrast
between the continence of the two figures
in the foreground compared to the background.
Ashton wonders if this is
from the Civil Rights period.
Mary Johnson noticed that the, all
the boys are behind the young woman.
As you're seeing this, try to connect with your
background knowledge so that we get some context
for why you're saying what you see.
[Inaudible] sees a young woman
who's wearing her best outfit.
Behind her are men who seem to be harassing her.
She feels sad and scared for the young woman.
[Inaudible] feels empathy for
her fellow black Americans.
Teresa thinks this is probably in the
south during the Civil Rights era.
Discomfort or different expressions
toward the camera.
Interesting that some people are
saying that she's very brave.
Braver than they are, and that
they feel shamed, nervousness.
I feel determination in the young woman's
face, which makes me feel admiration for her.
That's a great comment, Mary.
Carrie says at first she felt sad,
but she sees the determination grip
on the girl and the man's faces.
Really you can very well see that.
So let's move along a little bit now.
I'd like you to think about, what
makes you wonder about this image?
Share what makes you question in this image?
As you ask the questions,
you might look at the photo
and see if you can find any
clues to those questions as well.
Ashton wants to know what
happened before this photo.
I wonder why the man, if the man to the right
is the father of the young woman, right?
I wonder that as well, Patty.
Angie's wondering where this is.
Where is she going, and why
are they following her?
And who the young woman is.
Samantha wonders why there's so many teenagers.
And Theodore wonders what's about to happen.
And how does she feel, Lashaun.
I think Teresa wonders if it's
desegregation in a school in the south.
Carrie's wondering what's in front of them.
That's very interesting insight.
What's out of the frame?
That sort of goes to the purpose
or meaning behind the photo.
Teresa's wondering how large the crowd is.
So thank you for your questions.
I'd like to move along to an example of an
analysis tool that was completed with students.
Tools like this are available
from the Library of Congress.
And they help structure students' thinking.
But sometimes students have
difficulty completing the forms.
So, I'd like to point out that you'll find
companion sheets with guiding questions
in the teacher section of the
Library of Congress website.
These questions can be used as
a guide for the teacher to aid
in the investigation of the source.
Teachers use these tools in a number of
ways, and they ask students to create lists
with sometimes minimum numbers of
observations in each column or questions
to make sure there's enough information to peak
the students' curiosity and get their buy-in.
Have any of you used the primary source
analysis tools or those questions?
Anne, we will definitely be
sharing the URL for these images,
as well as where you can find them now.
And I understand that the
recording of this will be online
and on our slides as we point to things.
Most of our slides are hyperlinked to
the sources that we are referencing.
I see Samantha and David have both
used the primary source analysis tool.
Let's move on to the bibliographic
record for this.
So for those of you who have
used primary source analysis,
when might you use the bibliographic
record with your students?
Anne uses it after they observe the image.
And Anne, why do you choose
to use that afterward?
No, we're not having a conversation,
but you can give us more insight
after they've observed Lashaun.
Anne notices that you should
maybe get their reaction first.
And David says afterward.
After writing the questions, right Samantha.
A number of teachers use that.
We always suggest that it's important
to share the bibliographic record
as part of their finding the source.
But it also gives students an
opportunity to gain more information.
Did you gain a little bit more information about
this picture from the bibliographic record?
And what did you notice from the
bibliographic record about this image?
Date and place.
Interesting that Patty Wench notices
that, commented that she used
to not include the bibliographic information.
However, now she does because
it gives students more details.
You're right, Samantha, it is a school dilemma.
And it does provide more information.
So I'd like to move on now for
you, and notice that at the bottom
of the primary source analysis tool,
there's a further investigation box.
It can be used to help students
identify more important questions
and develop a research strategy
for finding additional answers.
Our sample questions are different from the
question box because we completed this part
after students had the bibliographic
information.
So we think that students can
use this information to move
on and do further investigations.
Our students ask, under the further
investigation into the time period,
what's the significance of the event?
And what connections can I make
between this and current events?
Anne likes customizing the questions
to fit the students and the content.
You can use the who, what, where and
when as well in further investigation.
I'd like to take a moment now
to give you a little background
on where you can find this information.
This is from an exhibition at the library
called Brown versus the Board of Education.
This photo we analyzed can be
found in this online exhibition.
You'll see here that there's some curator notes.
The curator note on the left provides
additional background information
to Miss Counts and the time period.
So if you were to look at this
image directly from the Library
of Congress, you would get a thumbnail.
And some of you who are familiar
with the library's resources,
understand that sometimes you have to go
to the library to get the larger item.
But through this online exhibition, you can
get the larger image and see it enlarged.
Are there any questions about
the short analysis that we did
on Dorothy Counts, Dorothy Geraldine Counts?
If not, I'd like to pass this
presentation baton back to Julie.
>> Thanks Mara.
I'd like us to consider, just
as you have all experienced,
how teaching with primary sources naturally
engages learners in the inquiry process.
To interact with primary sources, we must read
closely, evaluate the content and consider bias,
interpret perspectives, make inferences, ask
questions and pull together disparate pieces
of evidence to think conceptually
and draw conclusions.
With primary sources, there
are not easy or right answers.
Primary sources present multiple perspectives,
helping students recognize the complexity
of issues and to understand the importance
of context for credible interpretation.
Because primary sources represent
authentic voices and points of view,
students are better able to connect
with the content not only
intellectually, but also emotionally.
That personal connection inherently makes
the content more engaging and more memorable,
leading students to develop
enduring understanding.
Where there are certainly pros and
cons for our new [inaudible] standards,
when I first entered common
into our readings standards,
I immediately recognized the
processes of historian uses.
Tell us your views of the
ELA common core standards.
How have the standards impacted your teaching?
So you're not common core in Virginia, Patty.
But are you familiar with
the common core standards?
If not, we'll certainly give
you a taste of that tonight
and show you how common core really
aligns to primary source analysis.
So one of the things the CCSS represented a
shift from content to process-based standards.
So there is definitely a lot of
synergy between the literacy standards
and teaching with primary sources.
So, David talks about being more intentional,
about claims evidence and justification.
[Inaudible] is just starting.
Teresa talks about an approach and
writing objective based on the standard.
And then Andy talks about the standards and
inclusion of literacy across the curriculum.
I totally agree, Angie, I think
that is really a definite positive.
Lashaun is talking about making them more
deeper with the content and information.
Right. And images, especially, like the activity
we just did, are fantastic for helping students
to learn the processes outlined
in the CCSS literacy standards.
The primary source image analysis allows
students to focus on the acquisition
of these skills without the additional
cognitive load of reading comprehension.
So again, we're talking about how
we go from content to process.
It's really a process of historical inquiry.
And something that's important to remember is
that text can be any type of primary source.
When we say text, we don't
mean just actual text.
They can be images.
So let's break down a chart we created back
in 2012 to show just how closely the process
within its analysis mirrors the
ten CCSS reading anchor standards.
The standards text is on the
left as you look at the screen.
And the text on the right corresponds
to the process of image analysis.
Take a look at the words and
phrases underlined in red.
As you can see, completing an
image analysis as we did earlier,
aligns very well to anchor standard one.
We were analyzing the image, looking
at it to cite specific visual evidence
and using those to support our conclusions.
So there are really so many opportunities
to extend inquiry-based learning
while meeting the literacy standards
of primary source analysis activities.
So let's go on to anchor standard two.
For this standard you may have
students tell a story of an image
or explain the theme that it represents.
When you want to connect to anchor standard
three, you may have students work with a set
of related images to understand how
an event unfolds or a person develops.
Many students, and even adults, think
a photograph represents the truth.
But when we consider what might be happening
outside the frame or what happened right before
or after this moment in time, like some of
you noticed in our image and our analysis,
we learn that picture creators make
specific choices that help shape the tone
and the meaning we take away from an image.
Something that I think is really
especially important in today's day and age.
Asking students to consider how image
details relate to one another or to an image
as a whole is a similar process
to use in reading comprehension.
So this is a great opportunity for
students to practice key literacy skills.
Again, right where we're focusing on a process
here when we use an image and not worrying
about adding reading comprehension into the mix.
For anchor standard six, we can have students
to think about the point of view of the creator
and the creator's purpose in creating an image.
These are key historic inquiry skills, as
well as vital information literacy skills.
I think that is one of the,
just the absolute benefit
of primary sources is really always considering
what are we trying to tell the audience
with this piece, with this source.
So anchor standard seven seeks to
ensure that students interact with
and evaluate diverse content format.
So primary sources certainly
represent the diverse media.
For images, the point of view presented
is much like a textual argument.
All sources are biased, so it is
important to learn to evaluate the details
that support the particular point of
view presented in a text or image.
Sometimes I think there is that misconception
that primary sources are not biased.
But, of course, they are.
They're definitely representing
a particular point of view.
So we just need to make sure that we're looking
to try to determine what that point of view is.
Having students compare primary sources,
particularly different types of sources,
allows you to check into
different learning modalities,
which can lead to amazing connections
and enduring understandings.
And the final standard asks that
students become proficient in analyzing
and understanding different types of complex
text, which primary sources certainly represent.
They really run the gamut from something
that's pretty easy to understand to something
that really has multiple levels and
take quite some effort to unpack.
So, for information and advice on
selecting primary sources for the classroom,
as well as excerpting and
modifying primary sources,
visit the TPS-Barat primary source
nexus teaching resource blog.
Let's take a quick look.
As a consortium member in the Library of
Congress teaching with primary sources program,
TPS-Barat started this blog in 2011 to support
the program mission to foster knowledge
and use of teaching with primary
sources from the Library of Congress.
In that time, we've posted a lot of content.
From curated sets of primary sources and
other resources from the online library
to primary source teaching
strategies, lessons and activities.
Right now, with the start of National
History Day, we also have a lot
of resources linked to topic ideas.
Because the CCSS process aligns so well to
primary source analysis, you will find that all
of our instructional content aligns
to the standards to some extent.
Additionally, on loc.gov, under the
teachers section, you will find a wealth
of classroom material aligned
to the common core.
Let's take a closer look at the college
career and civic life for C3 framework
for social studies which was meant to help guide
the formation of state social science standards
but can also help teachers to
better define instructional goals
and devise implementation plans.
>> Julie and Mara, we have lost your audio.
Kathy, I'm going to propose
that I at least walk us
through the slides, just
in the interest of time.
And we'll trust that you'll
work behind the scenes
to get the actual presenters
up and running for this.
And we'll loop back and hit,
make sure we hit all the points.
So again, This is Cheryl Lederle
from the Library of Congress.
I'm going to be talking a bit through
these slides while Kathy, my colleague,
tries to get others up and running.
And I do hope they interrupt me very soon
with, and get the technical issues resolved.
So, they have noted that teaching with
primary sources supports the C3 framework
for social studies, which I noticed that
some of you are working with and some
of you are less aware of, and
some of you are just starting.
The four dimensions follow an inquiry arc.
There are four content areas.
And in building the C3 framework, there
was great attention paid to aligning
to the common core state standards.
The C3 framework has interdisciplinary
applications and points toward
and during understandings and preparation
for democratic decision-making.
And Anne notes that the democratic
decision-making is
so important for the social studies.
And I think we're aware of
that in an election season.
Here's a graphic of the four dimensions and
how they align to parts of the inquiry arc.
There's a focus on developing
questions and planning inquiries.
Perhaps a little bit familiar
from the earlier looking.
Do I hear sound?
>> Can you hear me?
This is Pam.
>> Hi Pam.
This is Cheryl.
I'm going to mute myself and
let you take over from here.
Thank you everybody for being patient.
>> We're going to talk a little bit about how
the four dimensions of the C3 work together.
You start by developing questions
and move on to investigate concepts
in core disciplines Then you evaluate
your sources and use them as evidence
to form the conclusions that you
communicate in an effort to illuminate
and act on your ideas and issues.
Dimension one is pretty self-explanatory.
But the framework makes it clear
that students need to be a part
of the question formulation process.
Through continued primary source learning,
you'll see that students automatically
get better at asking questions.
They develop hypotheses, make
connections and incorporate reflections
of prior learning into new inquiries.
To learn more about simulating student question
skills, check out questions are the engines
of intellect tomorrow at this time.
The C3 framework doesn't
prescribe to specific content.
And Theodore was asking about
content as opposed to process.
But there are target concepts and skills
practice within the four main disciplines
of dimension two, which are civics,
economics, geography and history.
But remember, these disciplines are
not meant to be taught in isolation.
Primary source learning naturally
provides cross-curricular connections.
And there are resources for teaching these
disciplines on the library's website, loc.gov.
We also have information on the
TPS-Barat primary source nexus site.
There are currently more
than 50 lessons and more
than 200 guided primary source
analysis activities targeted
for elementary, middle and high school students.
And they feature all kinds
of primary source types.
Okay, dimension three and four.
The analysis of primary sources is
at the heart of dimension three.
This connects both the research
and the verified basis of inquiry.
The communicate phase of the inquiry arc
is also carried out in dimension four.
Students take action because
learning is areflexic and recursive,
and communicating conclusions can lead to new
ideas to try out and new questions to explore.
As you can see, the connections
between the C3 framework
and the English language arts literacy
common core state standards are comprehensive
and touch all areas, reading,
writing, speaking and listening.
So let's think back again to our image
analysis that we did at the beginning.
And let's compare our work to the
dimensions by considering some questions.
Do we develop questions and
plan for further inquiry?
Which of the subject areas in social studies
might the particular image be analyzed
pertain to?
And how did they pertain?
And remember again, the four disciplines are
civics, economics, geography and history.
Now we found the source for
you, but who evaluated it?
You evaluated it, right.
And based on your reflections and inferences,
were you able to develop any claims yourself?
How might the image analysis activity
help you to communicate conclusions?
What actions might you take to
extend your newfound understanding?
So this is a quote from the
Guardians of Democracy report.
We also firmly believe that an
educated citizenry is essential
to the practice of representative government.
So today, when civics instruction
is taught at all,
it's often taught discreetly
as a standalone subject.
But while we teach with primary
sources in any subject,
we help students develop
civic competency skills.
So just what are these skills?
Let's take a look.
Capable citizens think creatively
and critically.
The Library of Congress has long realized that
teaching with primary sources engages students,
fosters inquiry, promote critical thinking,
enables the construction of knowledge,
and stimulates innovative problem-solving.
Capable citizens are information literate.
But what does that mean?
Multiple universities have defined the
information literate student as someone
who can determine what information
they need and figure out how
to find it effectively and efficiently.
They can evaluate the reliability and the
relevance of their information and connect it
to other information and knowledge.
And they use information effectively
to accomplish a specific purpose.
These are all skills that are reinforced
through primary source learning.
Let's take a look at how
six of Unesco's 11 stages
of information literacy are
supported by primary source learning.
With primary sources, information
is not spoon-fed to students.
Instead, they need to actively look
for and find information themselves.
When students analyze and evaluate primary
sources, they're creating new knowledge
and making sense of that
knowledge, thinking critically.
And learning how to analyze and interpret
primary sources provides students
with the opportunity to evaluate a variety of
communication formats and styles and helps them
to hone their verbal and written
communication skills for specific purposes.
Capable citizens are good communicators.
Here's a tweet shared last month by a nationally
recognized educator whose former student credits
her success at college to inquiry-based
lessons and learning with primary resources.
The tween contained this note from one of
the student's professors at Vanderbilt.
So take a minute and just scan this.
What an impact inquiry learning
with primary sources have.
I think we can all agree that this student
was certainly prepared for college.
Capable citizens are good collaborators.
The analysis and interpretation of
primary sources requires students
to consider multiple perspectives and
is often best completed collaboratively
to provide students with
different ideas and viewpoints.
And, as you can see in that top left
picture, even young students can engage
in the inquiry process using the
primary source analysis tool.
Okay. This year the Barat
Education Foundation and its partner
in the teaching primary sources program,
Constitutional Rights Foundation,
will be creating some exciting new
cross-curricular civics lessons
that incorporate primary
sources from the library.
In the meantime, please continue to look
for primary source sets, teaching strategies
and learning activities on the TPS-Barat primary
source nexus and be sure to follow us on Twitter
at PSNTPS to keep tabs on the
latest resources and learning.
And remember, when you teach with
primary sources, no matter the subject,
you are implementing inquiry-based learning
that aligns to the common core state standards,
supports the C3 framework,
and fosters civic literacy.
And our last slide is a slide with links to
all the resources that you can reference later.
>> Alright.
So well I want to thank our participants.
And I want to thank especially our
presenters today, Mara, Julie, Pam,
I know that we had some technical glitches,
but I want to thank you for a level
of professionalism that is just amazing.
So I thank you for your time and your expertise.
And if you have any more questions,
you can continue them on Twitter.
Thank you everyone, and we hope to see
you at more sessions tomorrow night.